Absolutely not.
Mothers are not taking on the shame of the state of the world.
We care. Thank you for saying that out loud.
Please go watch her original video.
Anytime a mother posts an opinion
or something she is choosing to do for her family,
there will be a myriad of comments
talking about how wrong it is for the planet,
society, and the environment.
Potentially the kids themselves.
This commenter is talking about paper plates,
but you could apply this to literally every decision.
Feeding your kid organic using cloth diapers,
breast milk first formula.
As mothers, we hold the pressure of making the choices
that are best for our family.
And to have people come into the comment section
and decide that we are what's wrong with the world
when women and mothers are literally horrible,
holding up the entire existence of not only our society,
but our economy. I also refuse to take that.
You know how many people have come into my comments
after I decided a homeschool
and say that? That's really disappointing.
You're what's wrong with the system.
I'm not what's wrong with the system.
I'm reacting to the system as our every single parent.
We all make the choices that we can.
We already carry so much guilt over everything.
I'm not carrying it for our world being fucked up too.